now u.s president joe biden has warned
russia's vladimir putin of strong
western economic blowback against any
attack on ukraine in a two-hour video
call between the two leaders president
biden voiced deep concerns over russian
troop buildups president putin said
russia will not attack ukraine but
demanded guarantees against eastward
nato expansion
it's a video call with war and peace on
the line
hello
good to see you again
for roughly two hours u.s presidents joe
biden and his russian counterpart
vladimir putin spoke about the future of
relations between their countries
but it's russia's troop buildup on its
border with ukraine that has prompted
fears of an invasion
president biden was direct and
straightforward with president putin as
he always is
he reiterated america's support for
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
he told president putin directly that if
russia further invades ukraine the
united states and our european allies
would respond with strong economic
measures
the kremlin is demanding legally
enforced guarantees that nato will not
expand further east setting up military
operations in ukraine and it wants the
u.s to promise it will not allow ukraine
to join nato the white house says it
warned russia that there will be very
real cost should it proceed with
military action and a tougher response
than when moscow annexed crimea
i will look in the eye and tell you as
president biden looked president putin
in the eye and told him today
that things we did not do in 2014 we are
prepared to do now he says the u.s
doesn't know for sure if russia plans to
invade ukraine the kremlin insists the
military buildup is just to protect its
border
putin said that you americans are
worried about russian battalions on the
russian territory
thousands of miles away from the united
states
well we are really worried about our
security
the security of russia and the global
sense on the global scale
neither side expected a resolution this
week but camps in moscow and washington
agree that communication is vital in
de-escalating tensions between these
former cold war foes
well for more on this we're joined now
by dr andres bratz he's an expert on
russia's foreign and defense policy at
the german council on foreign relations
and he joins us from budapest thanks for
being with us
dr raj we've got two major powers here
wrestling over ukraine what is russia's
concern about ukraine joining nato
first and foremost one needs to see that
it has always been a core element of
every russian leadership every
subsequent russian leadership
to ensure that nato does not get too
close to the borders of the russian
federation
nor does it deploy any offensive weapon
systems too close to russia
russia back then could not prevent the
nato accession of the baltic states
neither of poland because russia back
then was much weaker than it is right
now and moscow has really been concerned
about the possibility of ukraine once
joining nato we shall not forget in 2008
at the bucharest nato summit nato
promised ukraine and georgia nato
membership there is no deadline attached
to it but the promise has been there so
from the perspective of moscow this
bucharest promise this promise from 2008
is still valid so that's the main reason
why russia keeps voicing demands that
nato should give a guarantee that
ukraine would never make it to the
alliance that's basically the confusion
just briefly do you see any prospect of
that promise of nato membership for
ukraine being withdrawn
uh no but i don't see any prospect for
membership either
one
needs to realize i mean the alliance
never takes in a country which has an
ongoing territorial conflict
ukraine has actually two of that ukraine
has occupied crimea and ukraine has the
conflict in the east of the country okay
i wanted to ask you um about russia
because it's already taken ukrainian
territory in the form of crimea as you
pointed out if it were to further invade
ukraine as we're hearing from the white
house the u.s says it would respond with
severe economic sanctions some say the
north stream two gas pipeline between
russia and germany would be put on ice
do you think these threats impress
president putin
it depends on the very details of of the
economic sanctions
and the important element of this u.s
message that the u.s promised to respond
all levied economic measures not with
military ones
so the lack of mentioning of any
military response
indicates for russia that in case an
invasion happens yes there will be
severe economic consequences but the us
is not going to fight for ukraine
however
when it comes to the economic measures
uh what was what's public from the
discussion of president putin and
president biden is that the u.s promised
to hit russia's banking sector this is
one of the few sectors where russia is
still very much dependent on the west
and is very very vulnerable when it
comes to the global exposure of its
banking system
in other words
these severe economic measures
particularly if they include uh the
stopping of the north stream two gas
pipeline would deliver a major very
severe blow to russia
dr ratz thank you very much for talking
with us that was andhras rats of the
german council on foreign relations
thank you
you